vamos con la pregunta 21 nos dicen qué
producto es equivalente a 4x cuadrada
menos 16 sobre 2 - x ok y nos dan estas
cuatro opciones así que lo que voy a
hacer es bueno reescribir esta parte de
aquí arriba si factor hizo con un 4
entonces factor izando un 4 nos queda 4
que multiplica a x cuadrada menos 16
entre 4 que en este caso es 4 y abajo
nos queda igual
2 - x ahora en el numerador tenemos x
cuadrada menos 4 y eso es de la forma
cuadrada menos b cuadrada o sea una
diferencia de cuadrados y eso lo puede
expresar bueno ya sabemos que a cuadrada
menos b cuadrada es a más ve por a menos
b entonces en este cuadro en este caso
perdón es 4 x
en este caso es x veces 2 entonces es
más b que es x2 por a menos b que es x
menos 2 y todo esto entre 2 - x y hasta
ahorita parece como que no podemos
cancelar nada sin embargo puedes notar
que este x menos 2 se parece mucho a 2 -
x esencialmente si yo factor hizo aquí
abajo en el número bueno déjenme copiar
todo igual
x 2 x x menos 2 y aquí en el denominador
factor hizo un menos uno siguió factor
hizo menos uno voy a tener que
multiplicar a x verdad para que me dé
menos x y a menos 2 para que al
multiplicarlo por menos 192 ahora sí
notemos que tenemos el mismo factor acá
arriba tenemos este factor
tenemos este factor x menos 2 y este
otro así que estos dos los puedo
cancelar suponiendo que x no es 2 pero
si x fuera dos abajo tendría un cero en
él
y eso no se vale entonces 4 entre menos
uno es menos cuatro y al final sólo
multiplico a x2 y esto afortunadamente
es nuestra opción de nuestra opción de
vamos con el siguiente
tenemos esta expresión lo que nos piden
es simplificarlo y tú podrás decir oh
por dios multiplicar y simplificar esta
expresión me llevará una eternidad y
luego tenemos términos muy grandes como
de orden cuarta orden cuarto que se yo
no pero aquí es en donde el álgebra
viene a nuestra ayuda
por ejemplo bueno voy a copiar todo esto
es x cuadrada más 4 x sobre x más 3 x x
cuadrada menos 9 igual a x cuadrada más
x menos 12 muy bien entonces lo que
podemos hacer es ir factor izando esto
por ejemplo aquí puedo sacar yo un x
común que multiplica a x + 4 muy bien
esto así ahora esta es otra diferencia
de cuadrados esto lo puedo poner como x
+ 3 x x 3
ahora bien este no se puede simplificar
y éste lopo factorizar necesito dos
números que multiplicados me den menos
12 y sumados 1 así que se me ocurre que
puede ser x + 4 con x menos 3 ahora 4 x
menos 13 es menos 12 y 4 menos 3 es 1
entonces si funciona así que todo esto
simplemente lo puedo ya expresar como x
x x + 4 muy bien eso es esto primero
luego que multiplica a x + 3 x x menos 3
y todo esto dividido sobre x más 3
verdad esta parte de aquí que multiplica
a x + 4 por x menos 3 muy bien entonces
ahora viene la hora de la tacha de era
porque vamos a cancelar este con este
factor vamos a cancelar este factor con
este otro y tenemos este otro que se
puede cancelar con este y simplemente
nos queda x así que la respuesta al
final no
tan espantosa de hecho fue muy sencilla
y solo es x muy bien
vamos con el siguiente dice cuál es la
forma más simple de esta expresión y nos
dan esta expresión que está en términos
de xy de jay y demás lo que uno podría
hacer en principio es factorizar pero yo
creo que basta con escribir esto bueno
simplificar todo al dividir cada uno de
los sumandos entre 5x y verdad y si sale
entonces cinco entre 51 x cúbica entre x
es x cuadrada 10 sobre ye pues es 1 así
que ya no lo ponemos ahora 20 entre 5
son 4 x cuadrada entre x es x y ya
cuadra de entre y es muy bien ahora
vamos con el último 20 entre 5 es 4x
entre x es 1 así que no lo ponemos y el
cubo entre y es que cuadra de entonces
esta expresión no se parece en lo
absoluto a ninguno de estos así que lo
que eso sugiere es que tenemos que
factorizar lo todavía es decir
si yo bueno si nos damos cuenta la raíz
de x cuadrada es x verdad así que si yo
multiplico por qué número el doble de un
número por x me debe dar 4x y verdad
entonces y eso elevado al cuadrado debe
ser 4 y cuadrada si es que lo que
factorizar como un binomio al cuadrado y
eso por supuesto funciona si yo pongo
esto como x + 2 y todo esto
al cuadrado verdad el doble de este x
éste sería 4x y este al cuadrado sería 4
y cuadrada entonces está perfecto si
esto a lo mejor no tuvo mucho sentido
para ti multiplica esta bola
digamos multiplica x + 2 x x + 2 y vas a
ver que nos da justamente esto entonces
esta es la opción b muy bien sin si no
si no tuvieras idea de cómo hacerlo pues
desarrolla cada uno de estos y date
cuenta que debe ser igual a esto ahora
estos dos no pueden ser porque nos
faltan términos verdad a éste le falta
4x
le falta perdón a éste a este le falta
dicho más verdad en fin puedes ver cómo
descartar algunos y llegar al resultado
vámonos al 24 sí y es la raíz de menos 1
qué punto muestra la ubicación de 5
menos 2 y en el plano muy bien entonces
de hecho y es la raíz imaginaria verdad
es la raíz de menos 1 de hecho ya hemos
hablado de muchas propiedades muy
bonitas de la raíz imaginaria del número
imaginario y con cuando lo relacionas
con con el número e con el número pi y
demás entonces aquí me piden la
ubicación de 5 menos 2 y en el plano
esta es la parte real que se encuentra
se encuentra sobre el eje x aquí estamos
en 5 ahora bien nos dicen que la parte
imaginaria es menos 2 así que nos vamos
12 unidades para abajo y por lo tanto
nuestro punto en donde se localiza es
este de aquí ok y eso eso corresponde a
la opción de que tengo en el texto pero
bueno creo que bastaba con componer lo
de esta forma
muy bien vamos con el siguiente
número 25 dice sí y es la raíz de menos
1 cuánto es y a la 4 entonces vamos a
poner y es la raíz de menos 1 ok
entonces qué pasa si nosotros elevamos
al cuadrado tendremos la raíz cuadrada
de menos 1 al cuadrado pues debería ser
menos 1 ok ahora qué pasa si elevamos al
cuadrado en ambos lados nuevamente
tendremos menos 1 al cuadrado y cuadrada
al cuadrado pues esto se multiplican los
exponentes y me queda y a la 4 verdad
ahí ya tenemos ya la 4 ahora menos 1 al
cuadrado es 1 por lo tanto ya tenemos
que la cuarta potencia de la raíz del
número imaginario y es uno y eso es
bastante bonito y de hecho es la opción
sé que tengo en el texto
con el último
dice que número está el número complejo
está representado por el punto que se
muestra abajo muy bien entonces lo que
tenemos es nuevamente que esta es la
parte real y esta es la parte imaginaria
ok imaginaria vamos a ponerlo completo
entonces en la parte real tenemos tres
unidades aunque ya sí que nuestro número
en su parte real es 3 mientras que en la
parte imaginaria nos movemos 1 2 3 4
unidades muy bien entonces nuestro
número el complejo perdón tiene como
parte imaginaria a menos 4 que
multiplica a y entonces esta es la
respuesta y bueno estoy notando que ya
casi se me acabe el tiempo pero nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo